columnas de humo que se elevan hacia el
cielo mientras las municiones detonan en
medio de un incendio un depósito militar
ruso fue golpeado por una serie de
explosiones el martes en crimea el
ministerio de defensa ruso atribuye el
hecho a un sabotaje el gobernador de la
región nombrado por moscú dijo que no
hubo fallecimientos de momento tenemos
información sobre los heridos un hombre
fue alcanzado por un fragmento de
metralla el otro herido fue enterrado
bajo un muro he ordenado cerrar una zona
de 5 kilómetros la evacuación de todos
los civiles de esa zona de 5 kilómetros
está en marcha el incidente del martes
ocurrió cerca de la aldea de majesco y
al norte de la península a unos 110
kilómetros de novo fedor ifca allí es
donde una serie de potentes explosiones
golpearon la base aérea rusa de sacchi
el pasado martes destruyendo al menos
ocho aviones militares rusos en lo que
según las autoridades ucranianas fue una
operación llevada a cabo por las fuerzas
especiales en colaboración con los
partidarios locales
kiev también pareció atribuirse el
mérito de las últimas explosiones con un
asesor del presidente volodymyr selenski
twitteando que la crimea ocupada
consiste en explosión depósitos y alto
riesgo de muerte para los invasores y
ladrones calificando las explosiones del
martes como desmilitarización en acción
desde la anexión de crimea en 2014 el
kremlin ha fortificado y militarizado
fuertemente la península utilizándola
como base estratégica para lanzar
ataques contra ucrania durante la actual
invasión está fuera del alcance de la
artillería ucraniana con fuertes
defensas aéreas pero como demostró la
semana pasada no es invulnerable al
contraataque ucraniano